we love her that's liam hemsworth
sister-in-law Elsa Pataky talking about
his ex Miley Cyrus but it seems her love
for the singer may have changed as she's
speaking out about the former couples
split for the first time I think he's
gonna be really exciting in a recent
interview with Ola the 43 year old
actress said her brother-in-law deserves
much better
following the pair's shocking breakup
I'm horrible at secrets Elsa who is
married to Liam's brother Chris opened
up about how her brother-in-law is doing
telling Ola after a relationship that
you've dedicated 10 years to he's a
little bit down but he's coping well
he's a strong boy and he deserves the
best I think he deserves much better
everyone thought he was over Liam and
Miley called it quits in August 20 19
years together and less than a year of
marriage married life thank you I'm good
I'm doing good the news came as the
singer was spotted kissing Kaitlyn
Carter on vacation in Italy although the
women have that since gone their
separate ways
there's definitely a lot of surprises
Miley is now linked to another
Australian actor in singer Kelis Simpson
[Music]
the pair has been flaunting their
relationship all over social media is
that kind of bizarre I mean it I
there's no point denying it meanwhile
liam is rumored to be dating Madison
Brown although they've kept their
romance low-profile
since he filed for divorce from the
wrecking ball singer on August 25th
he'll be ok you notice he needed to take
care of himself a source told et at the
time that Liam realized it was time to
move on
adding Liam's decision to file for
divorce is sad but in the end it was
never going to work Cyrus his mom at
Tisch spoke out about how the 26-year
old singer is faring post-breakup just
days after Liam filed
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]